this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality best-selling
author is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money if you're familiar
with ken's show it's
broadcast now on about 75 talk radio
stations across america plus
big time podcast numbers and youtube
followers
and he talks about your career and
finding
joy in your work finding work that uh
has
meaning so if you've got career
questions job questions
maybe you're bouncing back after a
little covet 19 action i noticed we all
had a little of that last year well
ken's here to help
phone number triple eight eight two five
five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five ryan is with us in
cleveland ohio hey ryan how are you
hey sir how are you i'm great good how
can we help
got a quick question for you so i'm 24
years old out of cleveland ohio and
looking to purchase my first home and a
little worried
because of how the market is right now i
kind of want to just ask your opinion
you know with interest rates being so
low it seems like if you're not
the first offer and at least forty
thousand dollars uh over asking you
don't have a shot
so kind of wanted to ask your opinion on
that well i
i don't play those games i've bought
real estate my entire adult life
i own a bunch of real estate i bought a
piece of real estate last week
but i did not uh i did not uh offer
more than asking price in order to get
it
uh i don't get it caught up in that um
my guess is you offered quite a bit
lower yes no on this particular course
yeah i wish you
we were 35 000 over on our last um
house we looked at and we lost it yeah
well you didn't you weren't supposed to
get it it was a dumb purchase
that's exactly right and i'm thankful i
didn't get it yeah don't don't purchase
something thirty five thousand dollars
over asking
i mean you're not desperate man you're
24. you got a long time
it'll be okay now the thing is this are
you out of debt
i i am yes sir i've got no college loans
grateful for my parents that were able
to uh pay the bill for me to go to
school i work through school
and i'm about two years into my working
career good
okay what do you make uh 65 000
okay you're single i am single but a
girlfriend of six years
awesome okay and you are uh not
buying a house with her you're buying a
house by yourself
it is yep it's gonna be under my name
and uh she'll also
be helping to pay the mortgage nope
nope nope don't sleep with your partner
and it'll just be on me
don't sleep with your partners bad idea
you'll get yourself in a mess if you
want to if you want to
if you want to do that it's time to get
married uh but no you're gonna get
yourself into a huge mess if you've set
your life
up based on something uh based on a
roommate situation
uh so no if you're gonna buy you're
gonna buy based on your numbers or
you're gonna get married if we're gonna
base it on both numbers
because then you've got all kinds of
protection she has all kinds of
protection
she's not paying someone else's mortgage
on a home she doesn't own
i'm her dad right now i'm not going to
allow her to do that
that's a bad move for her okay
it will all be under me then yep all
right so you got your down payment and
you have an emergency fund right
yes sir i've got i've got money in the
bank and my other question too would
would it be smart to uh take advantage
of the fha
or should i just do it conventionally
conventional is the cheapest loan by far
a lot lot less expenses and you need a
good solid down payment 15-year fixed
where the payment's no more
than a fourth of your household
take-home pay
if you change your household by getting
married then you can recalculate that if
you don't then you're going to run it on
yours
now the deal is this there's a couple of
things
that cause people to get uh goodbyes
on anything real estate included number
one
is patience
if you get emotionally married to
something
you're gonna pay too much and it's dude
it's a stinking house
there's houses on every corner in
cleveland i've been there
there's a lot of houses in cleveland so
you don't need just
i gotta have this house you know when
you when you
when you get house fever like that you
need to go home take a cold shower
slow your butt down
slow slow
that's who gets the best buy it's the
second person that gets the next buy
next best buy is the person has the most
knowledge
so you learn the market you keep looking
at this neighborhood you're looking at
that neighborhood
you know the differences in them you
know the nuances you know the prices
over there
there's nothing in this neighborhood is
sold for more than 350 dollars a square
foot 250
a square foot 1250 a square foot
whatever it is
you know what it's going for and so
something comes on the market
that is uh you know you can look at the
numbers very quickly because you've
gathered information he with the most
information he with the most options
because you don't get emotionally
married to something and he with the
most
patience is the one who gets the best
buys
and a wise purchase slow your
butt down it needs to
in this market is hot white hot as it is
it may take you a year
to buy a house just enjoy the process
you're not dying paying a little rent
you're not gonna but don't go in there
and overpay
and it's just man i tell you what you
you smell like somebody's getting ready
to overpay because you got you're just
so freaking excited
he's in his early 20s he's in great
financial situation
the first house is the first house i get
why it's so exciting it is exciting
stacy and i bought a house uh two and a
half years in the marriage we ran in for
two and a half years
and we look back on that house now and
we go oh wasn't that cute
it's the first house it was nice it was
a good move for us we were patient but
it's the first house
and the other thing here and i'm not
trying to get in his relationship
business but
it's very interesting to me that he that
i don't know if he's talked to this girl
about this
or not but he was under the impression
that she was going to pay some of the
mortgage
and they've been dating for six years
and i think i don't want people to miss
the relationship piece as to why you
were so quick to go
hey whoa whoa we're not gonna do that
and that
you know six years we need to decide at
six years whether or not we're moving
forward or not
six years is plenty of time to decide
i'm a painter get off the ladder
yeah so why are we talking about going
into a co-mortgage situation with
someone you've been dating six years i
just think
that part of life has got to be figured
out first the first house will always
be there always slow down
just slow down
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five now here's what's
happened the real estate market is quite
hot
and so that's one of the things that you
need to get one like one of our endorsed
local providers
and you know you may have a high quality
real estate agent that says you're going
to pay
more than asking price to buy in this
neighborhood
in which case you just go well i'm
probably not gonna be buying that
neighborhood
take it off the list or i'm not gonna be
buying that neighborhood now
i'll just wait this thing calms down a
little bit it's okay
now is there a housing bubble is there
going to be a
drop in values no i do not think so
like i said i bought a piece of real
estate last week and by the way i did
pay
retail i didn't i didn't get a deal i
offered it
anyway get a deal right his kneecap is
sore
i bit him on the knee but i didn't but
it's okay you know but um
my wife was involved and when my wife
was involved i never get a deal
because it's s-w-i sharon she sees the
offer she goes sheridan wants it
[Applause]
you're gonna make them mad i'm like
honey it's a spiritual gift
oh my this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today i am dave
ramsey your host open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five roland is in oregon hi
roland how are you i'm good dave how are
you
better than i deserve how can can i help
well my wife and i have been doing the
baby steps
our entire marriage about 16 months
we've always been on the same page
and recently we did a zoom call with the
financial advisor that she had before we
met
he helped her set up a roth ira and
she wanted to introduce me and he
advised us
to be fully funding her 401 and also
be saving for a home while we're paying
off student debt and so
now she wants to throw your plan out the
window and i want to keep going like a
gazelle to pay that debt and
i don't know how to get her back back on
the plan
i don't either yeah
well she thinks now that that
your your steps are kind of a broad
stroke for people who are making poor
decisions and
they're designed for people like her let
me take a stab at this how much how much
debt do you have right now
134 134 000 made up of what
student debt all student loans yeah any
of that
any of that hers no sir it's all yours
how much do you make how much do you
make
i'm making none right now i'm a
full-time seminary student she makes
340.
she makes 340 000 a year yes sir
and and you're she's a doctor yeah
she is a a surgeon yes yeah
okay that's going to hurt my plan
because here's the stab i was going to
take and that is that she's got to see
that
while this guy has made this advice to
her that you still got this
debt and you're and you're it's going to
take so much longer to pay it off doing
it
his way in her way and you're going to
actually make progress faster part of
the problem dave i think is we've got a
uh
she's the full-time income she's the
only income and she's making big money
and she doesn't feel it doesn't hurt her
enough
the debt doesn't hurt and rowan i don't
know how to help you let me tell you
what you're experiencing
yeah 30 years of me coaching people in
finance
the worst people the worst
category of people handling money are
medical doctors
as a category they suck at handling
money
worse than pro athletes worse than
anybody
and the reason is is that they're very
very smart
intellectually and they make the mistake
of thinking that that translates to
finance
they don't know beans about finance but
they have an intellectual arrogance
and they go make stupid but decisions
and they firmly believe
with all of their intellectual arrogance
that they're making the right decisions
and it's the worst category now not all
medical doctors are that way but it's
stereotypical i mean i'm in nashville
with country music artists
some of them do some stupid butt stuff
some of them are brilliant with money
i mean i meet everybody from actors to
pro athletes
to whatever over 30 years the worst
category are medical doctors they are
perpetually in debt
and they're perpetually underperforming
in their wealth building
because of their intellectual arrogance
and that's what you're running into and
i don't know how to fix that
because now she and her little financial
advisor
who between the two of them don't know
beans uh about money
have made a decision so i really i i
don't know how to help you sir
how long before you get out of seminary
and start working it doesn't matter
i mean well it's 340 000 they could pay
it all off in one year
but i mean unless he convinces instead
the financial advisor kept her
is keeping student loans around like
they're a freaking pet
i got she got a hundred and forty
thousand dollars of student loan debt
she makes 340 000 if you can't pay that
off in a year you're a wimp yeah
it's ridiculous that this advisor takes
this poor
a stance and leaves this couple in debt
this far
you should be sued for malpractice as a
financial advisor for doing that
that's just asinine just
asinine but they're gonna do it
so i honestly don't know how to help you
that's what you're coming up against
though
and um truthfully some humility on her
part
is in order and saying you know what i
really don't know
anything about this area i just listened
to this one guy
and you know he disagrees with the other
guy
and so maybe now we can have a
discussion but no no no
don't doubt dave ramsey's a knuckle
dragger and his his ideas are primitive
and they're broad strokes how about the
broad stroke your idiot financial
planner gave you
there's a broad stroke for you so i mean
just just god aggravating his crud so i
i honestly don't know how to help you i
really don't know how to convince
someone
in that situation what to do i think
you're going to experience
pain before you do and i think you're
going to
experience that she makes a lot of money
and you're not going to get the
best use of it as long as you're
following this idiot that she had on the
phone well the one thing we can do is he
can if she's not going to get on
board then once he starts working he's
going to take all of his salary and yeah
but
now we're telling people split their
money apart and that's going to split
couples apart that's not healthy for
their relationship
well no i'm not one hold on i got to
because i don't want to confuse the
audience i'm not suggesting that they
split their money
i'm saying well they have a split plan
her plan and his plan
well but he's not going to not pay the
debt off yeah well he's got to pay it
off he is if he goes along with her
yeah so i mean you're not going to pay
it off for 30 years if he goes along
with her
yeah that's true i think he's got to sit
down and show her if we pay this off
look how much more we can invest how
much quicker that's the only shot he's
got it's
just a little she married a seminary
student so maybe we ought to read the
bible
there is borrower is slave to the lender
that's true about that let's try that
one
yeah i just don't the only thing is dave
i just don't think you were clear enough
with him and i don't think he showed
enough emotion
i feel like you mailed that i feel like
you mail that call in
no i get it it's frustrating it's a
tough situation because this is a
marriage well it is
and you know he's getting bullied
well okay so i'm gonna bring this up and
i don't and if you send a hate mail i'm
not going to read it so don't send it
uh well go ahead and send it we use it
for kindling yeah that's true we do we
use it for the fire pit out back yeah
um how much this has nothing to do with
her being a woman him being a man but
how much of this is the fact that it's
his
debt student loan debt and she's the
sole bread winner i think that's a
big factor in this isn't it it can be in
the fact that she doesn't think he's got
a vote
yeah that's what i'm getting at she's
going this is something should have been
handled before you get married i agree
that you know this is a messy
psychological deal given her
100 of their marriage she's gonna out
earn him
yes unless he has some kind of
ridiculous career in ministry that that
most people don't have right i mean a
pastor's income is not going to keep up
with the medical doctor's income
and 340 000 a year in 99
of the cases so this is going to be an
issue for 50 years
oh big time if that's if that's really
marital counseling
yeah just like any other problem with it
be parenting hey
she wants to discipline the kids this
way i think it's this way this is a big
issue this is marital counseling is what
this is this is the shot to get somebody
objective in there in the middle
let both of them hear each other out and
they've got they've got to fight on this
as a married
issue this is just like any other major
issue in your marriage in fact maybe
bigger let me explain to you what i'm
talking about because
some medical doctors are all mad at me
now because i didn't call all of you i
said the category
okay it's a stereotype right which means
that some people aren't right but
here's the thing the people that have
the most
trouble with money are oftentimes
the most that have the best and the
highest intellect
because they overthink it they think
it's a math problem
and personal finance is only 80 behavior
20 head knowledge it is a math problem
but it is not the problem the problem is
your relationships
the problem is understanding the flow
of your income and you know where it's
going to go
understand the spiritual principles that
are underlying all of this
and uh you know sometimes i run into an
accountant
or an engineer or i don't know
name somebody an attorney someone else
who you know
and there can be people in other
category career fields that have high
intellect but i'm people
people are highly intelligent and highly
analytical
and both also are the ones that struggle
the most to win
with money well remember this most of
the world used to think the world was
flat dave
and these people are running in a world
where it says you just go you get the
debt and you're eventually going to out
earn it it's not a problem
so if everybody says it then you just
believe it you should just do everything
at the same time
you need to get out of debt that's right
the world is flat
now we've confused everyone now i'm just
lost yeah
i am truly a knuckle dragger this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five if you
feel like you will always be stuck
paying off your debt well it doesn't
have to be that way
it won't take nearly as long as you
think it will with ramsey plus we're
going to kick you off
with a 90-day guided plan
to help you every single day exactly
what to do
small consistent wins that add up
to big results and better habits
you do not win with money you don't win
at anything big
all at once it's not sudden it's
incremental
you win death by a thousand cuts and
we'll show you how with financial peace
university
with every dollar premium with the baby
steps tracker all the tools are in
ramsey plus
this year can be your year if you want
to
do a free trial text the word trial
to 33789 if you want to take ramsey plus
as
a free trial you need to get in and look
at it text
trial two three three seven
eight nine and you guys have got your
six uh easy to use resume
templates to help you get noticed yeah
so we we had such success with our free
resume guide which is also at
kencoleman.com
and it came with a free template we had
so much response because we really flip
it on its head and you can learn more
about that as you read the free pdf
so we decided we got our world-class
designers and we've got a bunch of them
here in the building
and they created six new templates that
really kind of take in
all different uh styles uh also
industries and it lets you have for 9.99
six amazing templates to make your
resume stand out
and it's been a fun resource so it's a
way to to pull yourself out of the pile
uh to not just submit the free ones are
there free
and 9.99
789 as well resume 233-789
evan is with us in orlando hi evan how
are you
hey dave hey ken thanks for taking my
call guys sure how can we help
i yes my question is i'm wondering if
you guys have ever heard of
a million dollar baby plan yeah it's a
bad whole life policy for kids
okay i was just trying to figure out
because i heard it from my brother and
my alarm bells were going off when you
were telling me whole life and investing
yeah they should go off it's just it's
crap
it's just got a it's got a snazzy name
you know how you're going to get a
million dollars in there you put 2
million in
it's it's the old joke how do you make a
small fortune in a winery you start with
a large fortune
yeah they're playing on your emotions
it is a great name but the chances of
you ending up with a million dollars in
your baby's
whole life policy is almost zero i mean
you would have to put so stinking much
money in there the rates of return are
pitiful
they keep all the money that you put in
for the first three years
it is just a really bad
savings account with a life insurance
company
sucks beyond belief great name
i mean i pulled up one website it's got
a baby standing there
with a fistful of dollars yeah which
he's getting ready to give to the
insurance company
that's so true so
yeah i'm sorry your brother got got had
man tell him to run
well it turns out ramsay solutions has
had a million dollar baby plan
since inception it's called the baby
steps yeah well
because if you actually work them out
well you can actually invest money into
your kid's name
529 plan right you become a millionaire
and leave it to your kids
wow there you go that's how you do it
yeah yeah no
there's no free laws no no no no
whole life i love it they always go it's
tax-free growth
yeah not really that's true that's
semantics the only way you get the money
out that you put in
and not pay taxes on is you borrow it
and you pay interest
on your money so let me tell you
something if you put money
listen if you put money in a bank and
you've got two hundred thousand dollars
in a bank and cds
and you go borrow a hundred thousand
dollars out of that same bank while
you're two
and you pledge your 200 000 rcd against
it there's no taxes on that borrowed
money
there's no taxes on borrowed money duh
yeah borrowing money is not a taxable
event
right because you're but you're
borrowing your own stinking money and
paying them interest to get it out so
it's
time it's tax-free growth it literally
means it's
not it's an industry that's been
screwing people since
this is the power of marketing language
we to wake up
yeah but that's a great integrate title
billion dollar baby
are you kidding me what good parent
doesn't want to have i want
baby to be a million dollar baby i mean
you're not a parent
what kind of parent wouldn't do that
yeah rodney's with us in little rock hey
rodney how are you
doing well guys how about y'all staying
warm just barely brother how can we help
my uh so i'm in sales business
development good company
good industry and my question is
you know thinking back to college the
professors that really stood out to me
or
the ones that maybe just taught a night
class or or one class and
came from the business world and it's
something that i always thought about
maybe could you know do later and i was
wondering what would be
the way to to maybe check check into
that to see if that was something i
would be qualified for or even be
considered for a
you know a night class or one class
something like that at a community
college or even
a four-year school yeah well you just
you just put all the elements of your
plan
so here's what you've got to do so let's
start talking to the community college
and go hey i've got a college degree i
assume you do is that correct
that's correct so you got the college
degree and so the question is on the
community college level do i need a
graduate level degree to be able to be a
part-time professor
no and the answer is no and i think it's
probably no at your state schools as
well
so if you look at little rock you have a
phd in life my brother yeah
i think it's making connections so what
i'd start doing is is i'd go out of
class if it were me i want to make
connections best way to make connections
get in the places where the right people
are hanging out that is the essence of
the book the proximity principle that i
wrote and i'm going to give it to you as
my gift but here's what i would do go
audit some classes
they're going to allow you to do that
after the class is over all the students
file out
here comes a sharp business guy like you
who's on purpose and human
humble and you go to the professor and
go hey i eventually want to get in here
teaching some business classes or
teaching the class on this and this and
this and you do it
and you get clear on what courses they
offer
and you ask that professor to connect
you to who's in charge of that
they've got all the information they got
the connections and if they put in a
good word for you great and you go start
meeting people and sit down when they
see a guy like you who doesn't want a
full-time job
who just wants to do it for the love of
it uh and you've always wanted to do it
and they hear that from you that
enthusiasm that passion and that
humility say hey
i'm on call i don't need money i'll take
your part-time pay but i'm i'm here for
passion
i want to sign up what do you want me to
do any qualifications beyond my college
degree you want me to get yeah i'll go
do it and here's what's going to happen
eventually the phone's going to ring
well i don't think it takes that long i
don't either i'm
stroll into the president's office of
course you are
well to the president's community
calling well yeah but you're still not
strolling in that lady in charge of that
office is powerful i'm gonna stroll in
and talk to her
and tell her what i'm doing and say
listen i've got a phd
in life and i've got an undergrad and i
think i can teach a business class at
night i kind of want to do it for fun
um what's the what's the chances of me
talking to you guys about doing that if
they throw you out then go do ken's plan
yeah they won't throw you out
but right but these are yeah both of
those will work try both
yeah because i mean i don't think the
barrier of entry is that big because i
got to tell you
one of my favorite classes that i ever
took
was exactly what you're talking about
yeah i mean i was in
i got a degree in real estate and
finance and a guy that was doing real
estate syndication
doing what i wanted to do taught a class
called real estate syndication at night
i mean he was an actual practitioner you
know and oh my god i was
just dying it was like it was like elvis
if you were in the music business man i
thought
if i could just be in his class and i'd
do anything to take that class and i got
in there and took it and
and i learned a lot about syndication
from that class because a guy was
actually a
practitioner on his day job he was doing
real estate syndication
that's my whole beef with a lot of
colleges we got professors teaching you
theory they've never done it
and i tell young people all the time i'm
okay with college but you better go
spend some time with people that are
actually doing what you
want to do successfully because they can
teach you and
it's a master class over lunch for
crying out loud this guy
he'll have no problem getting in there
yeah i want to see him stroll into the
president's office so i'm looking
forward to stroll
just stroll don't walk strong that's
confidence
i'm telling you he's gonna get hired
immediately there's no question
go do that for sure this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones here on the ramsay show the
phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five
crystal is with us in newport news
virginia hi crystal how are you
hi thank you thank you for having me
sure
what's up um yes i was calling um
my husband passed away last year and um
it's been it's been a crazy year for
sure um
i'm a single mom i have 30 children
a 15 10 and six-year-old
at the moment my goal was to go back to
work but with this covet thing
that's going on i am currently a
homeschooling teacher um and it's just
not
not possible at this time i'm currently
bringing in about 30 grand
a month that i'm supporting the four of
us on
and i i just
when he passed we sold our house and i
moved into an apartment so i could get
my bearings
and i'm just kind of ready to get into a
more stable
living situation um an opportunity to
fall into my lap i'm doing dealing with
a special type of loans
that can offer me a lower house payment
as well as little to no down payment
and i can have an actual modular home
built for myself
and my children um
how old are you i'm actually about to be
36. okay what happened
um cancer oh no i'm sorry yeah
he um he was i was in school and
he got a stage four cancer diagnosis and
wow i put school on hold to take care of
him my children
and that was also on my list of
possibilities after he passed away i was
like well
maybe i can go back to school um but
again with this covet thing it's really
put me
in a bad spot yeah uh no the covet
thing's not put you in a bad spot you
lost your husband
world got turned upside down that puts
you in a bad spot
um i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
so um here here's um it sounds like
you've made some really wise moves
so far um
and uh and you have good instincts your
instinct is to try to get
things stable for your kids
in a world where your entire family's
world was turned upside down
and so you're clawing and scratching for
stability and
for for a solid ground and um
so i i think you sit right there in that
apartment
let's not do this house deal this is a
bad deal you're looking at
okay and it's a deal it's a deal that
satisfies you emotionally
but it is not um in a time when you're
hurting
but it is not a good long-term play
several things you said there were bad
words in the
in the world of your future and it was
modular
it was um nothing down it was a reduced
payment it was this is a special plan
um you know all of these things mean
that you basically can't afford to do
this deal right now and you're being put
you know you're being
sucked into something here that's not
going to be a blessing to you
i i want you to take the final stages
in the next 12 months out of your grief
into your future and as you do
those then make a decision on a house
but i think you haven't made the turn
completely yet because you don't have a
10-year plan to live like you're living
yeah your 10-year plan includes some
kind of a career move for you
and ken she needs to start taking some
steps that yeah i just wanted to ask
what were you going to school for what
was the vision you had a vision attached
to that
yeah nursing actually um
how much do you lack i'm about three
classes shy of applying to nursing
school
to nursing school yeah and then you got
to what a two-year plan
yes i mean it's been a little bit
nerve-wracking because
um you know obviously with the nursing
school itself it's very um
you have to show up every single day and
it makes it hard being again a single
parent
with three children um i just
so i i've i was assuming that i would go
back you have family in the area
um very little a lot of my dependencies
relies on
my 81 year old grandmother um
where is your family um
just various situations my mother how
did you all end up in newport news
well i i was born in newport news oh
okay um
yeah so we've been around a lot it's
just that like i said stability is not
all there
my mother had a stroke when she was 32
and she's
disabled and you know my father i just
got
him into rehab a couple years ago and
he's been
yeah i'm sober now for two years almost
every two years in may
um honey you've had enough crisis to
last anybody
yeah crystal crystal i want to encourage
you crystal i want you to hear what i'm
about to say
so right now you are in a storm
and that storm's not going to last
forever um
kids get back into school that's going
to alleviate a lot of things
i want you to focus on trying to build
some community whether you
try to go to church or you begin to
really seek relationships because there
are people out there who want to help
and will help you and you've got to be
okay saying i can't do this
on my own but you've you're doing a
tremendous job
right now on your own but you're not
going to have to always be on your own
you need to embrace that
now here's what happens once the kids
situation when you're not home school
teacher once that begins to alleviate
we want to get you in a situation where
you can finish those classes and if
you've got to press
pause for a little bit before nursing
school to get a really good paying job
and get out there and save and save and
save and cash flow your way through
nursing school even if that takes you
three to five years did you get
uh life insurance you can do it yes um
i i i had about um i have about 55
000 in a savings account that i haven't
really messed with too much
good keep that i had a 7 800 credit card
from him that
i i've been paying off i've got it down
to about 58 now and i've got
30 20 about 29 000 in student loans so
far
it's just um all right we're gonna we're
gonna send you a bunch of materials
we're gonna walk with you we're gonna
send you a bunch of materials we're
gonna send you ken's book on careers
okay i'm sending you anthony o'neil's
book called debt free
degree a new way of thinking about going
to school and not going into debt
and then we're going to put you into
ramsey plus which is our master class on
financial peace university it's got all
the stuff in it
we're going to pay for every bit of it
okay we're going to come around you put
our arms around you all right
i certainly appreciate it i like i said
i just didn't know what direction really
to go with it you know
my husband i want you to wait on buying
a house until after nursing school
yep with um with the actual apartment
situation the one that i'm currently in
i wouldn't say is necessarily the
greatest neighborhood and there's been a
couple incidents uh
there's a gentleman that was if you need
to move and rent a little house
somewhere that's fine but i would not
buy a house right now
right okay crystal you listen your
brain's on fire
yeah you got so much going on you've had
so much coming at you
that it's very difficult to make large
financial decisions
when you have this much of a cloud over
uh you know three different directions
yeah
every different direction every morning
you wake up with a new idea yeah you
know crystal i
want you to hear this crystal listen
dave gave you great financial advice you
got to get your financial house in order
first here's what i want you to hear
nursing school is still going to be
there yep the very reason why you wanted
to be a nurse
and caring for people it's still going
to be there
it's not that far away don't you let
this storm of life discourage you
and confuse you from what you want to do
and that nursing job
is not going to just be something you
love to do but it's going to be
something that takes care of those three
kiddos
get your financial house in order do
what we tell you take all the gifts
stay focused don't quit you're gonna
come out of this storm and when you come
out of it
we get our financial house in order and
then we move towards nursing you're so
close
don't you dare quit yeah i ken's exactly
right let me tell you what i heard okay
i'm talking to a 36 year old right
that's what she said yes 36 okay
when you're 56
you have had a long nursing career
working as many hours as you wanted to
work
and you're probably going to have close
to a million dollar net worth
that's exactly the end of this story
beautiful vision
you're going to be there and i'm going
to show you exactly how to do it and
ken's going to show you exactly how to
do it so
he's right you but but we don't need to
take any missteps
along the way to keep us from getting
there you can do it you hold on kelly's
going to get you signed up for
everything
as our gift garland i'm so sorry
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career your hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
the proximity principal is my co-host
today which means we can talk to you
about not only money but careers because
that's what the ken coleman show does
every day for a couple hours a day so
we'll talk to you about your future and
your income side of the equation i can
talk to you about both sides of the
equation the income and the outgo side
we'll just generally jump all up in your
business because it's what we do here
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two two five kevin starts off this hour
in greenville south carolina hi kevin
how are you
hey dave it's it's an absolute pleasure
to talk to you i've been listening to
you since i was 19 years old
33 now and i just wanted to say thank
you so much for everything you do
thank you sir how can we help well i'll
be brief um it's uh two quick questions
if i can
the first one um is i'm in babies four
five and six
i make 120 000 a year i'm married
and i'm 33 i'm getting near 100 000
in my uh roth iras and 401ks and i
started looking into the self-directed
iras to invest in real estate because i
heard that
i had heard from previous episodes that
you recommend doing that
um my question is that i'm trying to
find a good company and i notice that
there's no fidelities or vanguards
uh in in this in this space is there any
companies that you would recommend
that do this type of uh uh
no i don't have one that we recommend
and i generally don't recommend it
unless someone
uh is really really hot on real estate
and knows their stuff in real estate
it's not a beginners
if you're a beginning real estate
investor i wouldn't put my 401k money
into that
uh now i do know people that have done
very very well with it and of course the
rules are that all the money made
on the real estate whether it's from a
flip or
from the rental income has to stay
in the ira the ira has to fund
everything
and all the money stays in there so it's
not like you own a real
rental real estate and you get a rental
check and you get to put in your bank
account
you don't it has to stay inside of there
and so you're managing this property
for your retirement years not for
today's income
and that's what you've really got to get
your head around and that's what's
it's very constricting in a lot of ways
but what it does do
is it does free up a bunch of capital to
pay cash for some real estate and those
kinds of things
typically you can find a local bank that
has a self-directed program
and you can look into that and there's
probably a few places online and i would
just shop them out
but i don't have a particular uh
company that we say do that with and
i don't know if any of the smart mr pros
would have that or not
uh because it's not what we send people
to them for
so i don't know i mean they're helping
you just do a traditional 401k or roth
iras or
those kinds of things your 529s for your
kids college all that kind of stuff
and so i don't know you know you could
ask a smart investor pro in your area
they may actually have the service
through their broker dealer that they
can do that with but most of the time
uh we do not recommend my personal
401k is not a self-directed plan my
personal ira is not it's just in mutual
funds
just like we teach everybody else to do
now i buy a lot of real estate but it's
outside of that
and the the constricted portion of that
is there ken i knew a guy when i was
doing real estate deals back in my 20s a
thousand years ago
that um retired
from uh kodak that's how long ago it was
oh
wow yes kodak was a company a big
deal that was a huge company back in
those days i mean this is 40 years ago
35 years ago
and he had like in those days a lot of
money half a million dollars
and he took that and started buying real
estate and flipping with it and ended up
with about
two or three million dollars with real
estate in his it was his old 401 k and
he rolled it over into a self-directed
when he retired and did did real estate
deals in it but again
you have to have an income to eat with
other than that because you can't touch
that money it's trapped
in there until you're 59 and a half now
in his case he was over
59 and a half so he could pull money out
without penalty but it's like pulling
money out of your retirement account
and if i heard you right he knew what he
was doing this was
he was he was a seasoned real estate
investor yeah not a good idea for a
rookie just to play with this game yeah
i wouldn't use my my retirement plan
right if i'm
for my first five deals you know i
wouldn't i think it's very dangerous
because you know real estate is starting
your own business is the american dream
buying and selling real estate seems to
be the american dream everybody wants to
do it and i've done both
in my life a lot um
and so i don't recommend against those
things
what i do want everyone considering
either one of those things there's a lot
of people
uh in their 20s right now it's like it's
just this there's a
a surge of entrepreneurism
right now for people in their 20s which
is wonderful for america it's wonderful
for them uh
but the the thing is it it
starting running your own business is
probably 10 times
harder than you think it's going to be
there's a
i mean it's just going to take a while
and you don't know what you're getting
into and you're going to stumble around
and you're going to bump into stuff in
the dark and bloody your nose and the
same thing's true with real estate
you know everybody says well you just
buy a house and use flip house and he's
like they've been watching too dead gun
much cable tv
and some you know guy you know you see
an edited version of reality
uh in a reality show and some guy walks
in and buys a house and they change the
kitchen out or some kind of crap
it's on tv and it absolutely does not
work that way out here in the real world
well they'll
they'll go in and say oh this wall has
to come out it's got all kinds of rod in
or whatever and they go well it's going
to add to the budget
and then we move to the next segment
yeah it doesn't happen in the real world
it's more expensive
than you think flipping houses but
here's what's going on there's a lot of
people out there praying on these young
kids
20s and 30s going this is the get rich
quick
debts good use debt to your advantage
and they're not telling the other side
of the story
yeah and that and this isn't the horror
story it's not like we're talking about
the
one percent chance no you're guaranteed
to run into bigger problems than you
think flipping houses it's always more
expensive it always takes more time
contractors don't show up exactly when
you when you want them to
so in the 90s dangerous in 1985
i bought a package of 12 houses a
package
of 12 houses okay i was 24 years old
wow for 240 000
one of them i paid 13 000 for in that
package
basically it was a pack from one guy who
was going broke
these were these were run down houses
beat up houses in a bad neighborhood
that was
in air quotes historic and coming back
now 40 40 years later it is now a big
deal historic area right right but 40
freaking years later right okay or 35
years later
one of the houses had they built the
houses in a building boom
some of them with green lumber and the
reason the floors were warped was not
because they were old
it's because there's that lumber drive
that pretzeled yes
and it got hard as concrete so jacking
those floors up and getting
them even took weeks and months
i had that house jacked up with floor
jacks
and posts under it letting it settle
[Music]
this is how bad the neighborhood it was
they stole the jacks
out from under the house one night they
don't
tell you this stuff that's not only
cable tv it's not that doesn't come up
on cable tv
ever really happened oh how the house
didn't fall on the moron's head is
beyond
me it's unbelievable this is the day
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
do
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today i am dave ramsey your host
open phones at
825-5225 rob's with us in virginia beach
hi rob how are you
hey mr dave hey ken how you guys doing
great man how can we help
um so unfortunately i got a divorce
recently
about a year and a half ago and i'm on
baby step two currently
and i co-signed for the car that she
currently drives
and as per the divorce decree she's
responsible for the payments and she's
been making them
as except for a couple which have
negatively impacted my credit
but i was just wondering do i need to
add like
our joint car loan in baby step 2
as part of my debt or do i go by the
divorce decree and let her continue
making payments and just kind of monitor
it
well every time she doesn't make a
payment on time it's showing up gonna
show up on your credit report
yes sir she's only done that once
fortunately but it
hit it hit pretty hard it dropped at
about 75 points so
um that was about a year ago and i was
just wondering
um in baby step two if i need to add her
car on the list or not
no you don't but you need to get that
car paid off
and get it off your name so how are you
going to do that
how are you going to do that i tried i
tried to do a transfer of equity but her
credit score isn't good enough so it
defaulted back into my name and she also
tried to refinance
in just her name but unfortunately she's
the type of personality that if i start
helping her make payments or make
put even a dollar towards it she'll um
stop paying it completely
so that's just what i'm trying to avoid
because so what is the
what is the balance on the car she owes
about 23
000 still good lord no you do
so what should have happened in the
divorce decree was the sale of the car
yes sir it should have been a forced
sale and so
um
what do you make a year currently i make
80 000 i'm a disabled veteran
so i'm at 100 right now with the i'm
trying to
eventually get a home next year so i'm
trying to be debt free this year
because um it's still counting as long
as that car loan
as long as that car loan exists you're
not debt-free
yes sir because there's your name on it
yes sir
oh i'm sorry well thank you for your
service um
thank you for your support i uh what
does she make
um she was a server last night i spoke
to her we're not on speaking terms
was kind of a nasty divorce
unfortunately
so last i know she makes around 23
i believe okay so she has a car she
can't afford
yes sir and i think she's too stubborn
to go ahead and admit that and sell it
so that well um
what i would do what i would do is if
she misses another payment
i would uh hire an attorney and drag her
back in before the judge
and ask the judge motion the court for
the car to be sold
yes sir as soon as she misses one
payment
okay because like i said i'm trying to
i'm tired of renting
and well the bottom line is that's
what's going to help her
is to get rid of the car and it's also
going to help you
because she she cannot if she's making
twenty five thousand dollars a year she
doesn't need a twenty two thousand
dollar car payment
that just doesn't once they paid off
yeah sorry go yeah and so and and i
don't want you to pay the car
off i want you to force her to sell it
now if you could convince her
that it was in her best interest to sell
it because it is
um or if you have anyone that you know
that can speak into her life
that could convince her um to
sell the car it would be in her best
interest it also by the way would be in
yours
but i mean actually yeah
if she gets a hit at all that is in my
best interest she's less likely to do it
basically
well i mean it's obvious it's in your
best interest you owe the money on the
you're on the car loan she knows that
but that's not the motivation here the
motivation is
she if she's got to get rid of this car
payment because
and she can't and so it's killing her
it's eating her alive and so she's going
to miss another payment
if you can't get word to her or get her
to somehow
listen to sell the car just go ahead and
have some money set aside for an
attorney
and the first time she misses a payment
immediately petition
follow file a motion with the court to
have the car sold
because she's not the court decree the
divorce decree demands that she pays the
payments and she's not paying them
and she's damaging you and when you get
before the judge you can say
oh by the way you're on it she makes
twenty thousand dollars a year she's got
twenty thousand dollar car payment it's
not good for her your honor
and he would look at her or she will
look at her and say oh yeah you need to
sell this car kid
that's a bad deal and they'll they'll
help her
adjust her attitude that's one thing
judges are pretty good at
they take great great pride in that well
i mean a lot of them
honestly at that level a lot of the
judges are not it's not like tv they
really do care
and they actually will look at you and
go you know that
they use wisdom oh it's like the parent
many people have never had exactly
exactly i mean uh you know we do a lot
of work with the uh
uh the foster care system in tennessee
and so we've got to know a lot of the
juvenile court judges and stuff and
i got to tell you they're they're the
best social workers on the planet
i mean they really uh they care and
they've got the power to do something
about it too
so uh it's um just it's just wisdom
and this this poor girl is not being
wise it's not good for her
stephanie is in orlando florida hi
stephanie how are you
hey thanks for taking my call um i want
to know
how much i should switch my car i have a
03
um ford expedition i love it but it's an
o3
um i have about
15 in my emergency fund um
and then we have about 25 in another for
savings money to make
about 250 a year um
but i just don't want to spend more than
i spent on
some investment houses for a car you're
going to
you make 250 000 a year you're driving a
piece of crap
yeah i know but it's a to b
i get it it doesn't take much to make
you happy and you're a content person i
get that but
you're you know i don't you know i'm not
big on
i i'm the guy tells everybody sell their
car right i'm not the guy tells people
buy cars but you need to buy a car
darling
well what is reasonable for a car
like because i'm looking at and well you
have 20 000
set aside for buying a car okay
and that's that's only ten percent of
your income
yeah and so it's not it's not
unreasonable to spend twenty thousand
dollars on a car and you can get a great
used car for that
car okay you had a ton of car wonderful
car for that
um okay so take cash and you should
never have
all of your cars and things with motors
and wheels added together
that you own should never equal more
than half your annual income because all
of those things go down in value but
we're not even approaching that
oh no i won't sell that much stephanie
listen let me set you free you got 20
000 i think that's your budget that's
the top
and knowing you you're going to go shop
and you'll probably find something for
17 that you love
exactly so or you might find something
for 20 and you offer them 17 or 15 and
they talk
i forgot the dave deal yeah if your
budget's 20
always offer 15. not a dime more yeah
man
because you could always come up what's
the worst they can say everybody needs
to sell a car i'm just saying and she
needs to buy one so it's a match made in
heaven man i mean
listen you taught this years ago and
it's true i did this i remember uh we we
we were living in atlanta
stacey i hadn't been married that long
and uh it was time for me to upgrade i
was driving like
literally garbage on wheels and it was
time
and i jumped up a little bit i think i
think it was a five thousand dollar car
at that point we were still paid off
debt no we paid the debt off sorry but i
first the first car it's like okay now i
can afford something and i
the the car was 7 500 for some infinity
something or other
and i took five thousand dollars in cash
in a 100 yes 800
bill and i put it on the back of the uh
on the on the trunk i did my best to fan
it out but i was shaking
yeah because i'd never done it before i
was trying to summon dave
and there it is there's a deal right
there you're gonna sell my car he said i
can't do it for five
i said well that's what i'm offering he
goes would you take he says would you do
it for 55 and i said
yes before you quick you should have too
quick
quick shake shake i don't know man
so that really does work especially if
you're buying private party yeah
absolutely unbelievable it absolutely
does
cash still talks baby this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure or you
pick the wrong color they will remake
your window blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run all the
time you save even more
always use the promo code ramsey
which means you heard it on the ramsay
show ramsey
blinds.com pretty impressive it'll save
you some money all right ken what do we
got today's question comes from jack in
pennsylvania says i'm struggling to
decide whether to leave my job i'm a 31
year old attorney making
154 000 a year i've been the in-house
counsel
for family owned business for two years
a
very profitable company but our boss and
founder has severe personal problems
he's engaged in illegal drug use for
decades
and suffers from severe mental illness
everyone in the company is afraid of him
and morale is low
we stay because our high salaries and
fear
that every boss is like this am i a
crybaby for wanting to quit
no you're not a crybaby wait a minute i
don't have any illegal drug use yeah i
do have severe mental illness
well it depends on what article you read
it has been reported that you do i will
tell you that
that is that is true uh but let me just
blow this myth up every boss is not like
this
you know i know dave that a lot of
people who are in toxic work situations
what happens is it becomes so toxic and
there's a fear of
change
domestic violence it is they'll put up
with it because i found that humans are
are more willing to be miserable than
uncomfortable
and when he leaves this is a successful
lawyer 31 years of age making 150 for a
year you can make that somewhere else i
would suggest to you there's several
places
jack where you can make way more than
that as a lawyer so number one
every boss is not like this number two
you're not a cry baby you should quit
but i don't believe in jumping
even at the money you make so here's
what i'd say bite the stick start
looking
find something else sign a deal and walk
in there and say
it's been great i'm out yep yep and
don't try to
uh rebuke no i'm mentally ill no toxic
no sense in blowing up a bridge
no just go uh it was good thanks yeah i
got i'm moving on
bigger and better things next appreciate
the opportunity next year
yeah my goodness drug use for decades
and you're an attorney yeah yeah and
you're in you're
you're an accessory what yeah dave i
just want to say something really quick
on this i just because i hear this every
day on the ken coleman show i'm trying
to help people
pursue meaningful work so if you're if
you're new to me here on the ramsay show
that's what we're doing because we
believe that
that that everybody longs to make a
difference in the world and through your
work
and your relationships is how you do it
we focus on the work side
but i see this every day and here's
another case jack represents
all of us and there's so many of you out
there that are watching listening today
and you know you're supposed to leave
for a myriad of reasons it's not where
you're supposed to be
and and one of the big reasons that
people don't leave dave is because
they're so scared of the unknown and so
they're like i'm miserable but i
know what misery looks like i don't know
what change looks like
and so here's how you step into that
when you the fear is of the unknown so
what's the antithesis to that the known
go get some answers
go dig go do some research this is a
require resignation letter
go look go look and begin to see what's
out there when you begin to see the
answers
and then you see oh there's a path and
there's another stone and another stone
another
and then all of a sudden it's not so
scary but i'm telling you
uh fear of the unknown is keeping people
from from leaving miserable situations
number one
and finding meaning in their work to
show up every day
like i do here and get to do something i
love that produces results that
we were out feed my soul yeah we were on
the farm the other day and um
doing some shooting a bunch of us and uh
doing some
tactical pistol stuff anyway one of the
got his truck stuck in the mud
and you know there's two or three we
know number one somebody else can pull
you out yes
that's what ended up happening here
actually but um but i've got my truck
stuck
in the mud many times and you know one
thing you have to do is you have to
kind of get you gun it and get it moving
and kind of get it rocking back and
forth
and and then you gun it and you jump out
of it you don't
you don't kind of like crawl slowly out
you got to get a little rock going
that's it then you got to punch it so
jack what i'm going to tell you is you
need to get a little rock going and you
need to punch it
meaning that your hesitation in this
highly toxic situation
is going to lead you to want to stick
your toe in the water i don't want you
to stick your toe in the water i want
you to go
on 10 interviews in the next 30 days
that's exactly i want you to do this get
it i'm out
go yes you got to get out of there
now yes and you need to go look for
lots of jobs and interviews and all of a
sudden you're going to get confidence
that
it's okay yes and but you can't go on
one no
no and here's the other thing once you
do this jack you're going to find
that this is the nudge you've been
needing you finally got to your breaking
point please don't be like jack jack's a
good guy but don't wait until you're
miserable
you don't even have to work for a bad
company you just got to not like that
company
that's all it is like we've got one of
our senior developers here the
top top web guy or when you're uh
coding yeah you know what uh techno
technology guys senior developer i mean
this is big time oh yeah and he worked
at microsoft for a while
and matter of fact before he came to us
he left seattle and came here came to
work for us
and he was one of the top guys i mean
some of the stuff he wrote inside
microsoft was
absolutely amazing and so why did he
come to work for ramsey well number one
we won
best place to work last year in the
nation okay
and microsoft didn't okay they're not a
bad they're not bad people i'm not
running them down
but he looked up and said i want to
write code for
and i want to train young coders how to
write code for
something that matters yes i don't want
to just write it just out into oblivion
yes just ones and zeroes out into the
universe you know and not have any idea
that it
changed someone's life but when you're
writing code you know here
it's life-changing you're setting king
coleman up
to completely change the entire culture
in america
away from toxic work and you're setting
rachel cruz and ken and chris hogan and
dave ramsey up
to get to change the entire culture
inside of america when you're writing
code
to create a situation where the credit
card becomes the cigarette of the
financial world
where peop where so many people have
paid off their student loans
and gotten free that their life was
transformed
because people like you were writing
that code he wanted to be involved in
something like that
and by the way we're hiring more yes
right now yeah we need them we got lots
of technology needs right now lots of
senior coder you're out there listening
man i need you you know product
designers we need you
uh you know front end back end platform
we need you
i mean we need you you go to
daveramsey.com and click on the we're
hiring thing i mean i'll just turn this
into an employment ad yeah by the way
tell them that ken recommended you and i
might get a little bit of a bonus on
that does that work that way dave no it
doesn't are they acting hard for the tax
they have to know me no
no you don't get anything i thought i
was going to get that
no you're not you're not in that you're
not in that you're not that's not part
of your comp plan again
i folks we are looking for this is a
toxic work environment ken you don't
have any money for that
[Laughter]
but you were saying i'm sorry i was
having fun because we recommend people
now i mean but the point is
yeah that you know what we've got we've
got we have we have we have
we have a legal team here we've got a
you know chief council that's right
several attorneys on our sharp lawyers
because we've got all these uh
governance and all these contracts and
all these other things that we get into
hardly ever get into litigation but
occasionally we have to deal with that
too
but uh most of them is trademarking and
all these other stuff
and so you know that the guy that's our
senior legal counsel same situation he
came out of
uh you know a situation that wasn't
toxic
it wasn't that bad but it was just
didn't matter
what he was doing wasn't making a dent
in the universe
you know apple i love that was one of
their vision things i want to make a
dent in the universe
we want to make a dent in the
transformation of people's lives in
ramsey and we are doing that absolutely
we're in the process of doing that i
mean we're
we're changing massive numbers of
people's lives here absolutely and so
when you're our legal counsel
you know you're not having to work for a
guy like this guy and no you're not a
crybaby for wanting to have
meaning to your work that's just called
being wise by the way that's written on
your heart
i'm just going to tell you your creator
writes it on your heart nobody has to
teach a person
to want to make a difference you know
just like you don't have to teach a
toddler to take a toy from another
toddler or a lie
or to say no that's it's all on we all
want to matter we want to make a
difference and some of you listening
right now
are doing the right thing in the wrong
place some of you don't know what the
right thing is some of you know what it
is
but you know how to get there some of
you know what it is know how to get
there and you're scared to take the leap
uh we'll take those calls dave and i
would love to help you on that
we believe in you because we believe
that you were created philly unique role
that you were needed and you must do it
yep kencoleman.com to get information on
what ken's talking about daveramsey.com
if one of those
positions sounds like something you need
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five tax season is upon us i know
try to contain your excitement no one
likes doing taxes
especially after a year like 2020 man
it's a hassle to begin with but then you
go look for help and these so-called
free
tax software tools get you knee-deep in
the filing process and then they sucker
punch you with add-on fees
and they want to pitch you like 16
credit cards and a mortgage
i want to try to get you into debt i
thought i was just here to do my taxes
thank you turbo tax drive me nuts man
there's a better way to do it it's
announced this year a brand new thing
it's called ramsey
smart tax our team's brand new tax
filing software it'll help you file with
confidence ramsey smart tax
you get upfront pricing no credit card
pitches
no other side deals it's a killer deal
no tricks
simply help you do your taxes that's
simple text the word tax
to 33 789 hardly costs anything
tax text the word tax to 33
789 regina is in las vegas nevada hi
nagina regina how are you
great dave it's a pleasure to talk to
you and ken it's wonderful to talk to
you i love your show i just saw matthew
mcconaughey so that was wonderful
thank you thank you wonderful now dave i
have to pick your brain so this is my
story
i'm a long time listener and i'm a
first-time coordinator very happy
coordinator by the way
thank you um i'm working back at 37.1
working hard my only bed is my car about
to pay it off by september because it's
on the budget and it's an online item
and it's on strict
allocation great um the issue i am
having
is i have an attorney bill that's 14 000
and just growing exponentially
i have a line item in the budget for it
but i just don't have a big enough
shovel
i'm working day and night i've got four
jobs
and this build is not going to go away i
have an ex-husband who
loves to play games so my attorney has
told me in an email
that i either need to get a loan or
borrow money from my children
or he will not represent me i'm stuck
what would you do
uh so the ongoing hassling is over
child uh visitation
and child custody issues
it's basic he wants more he wants more
he wants more of him more
i pay child support he wants more so it
just keeps going every year
between i make 42 a year
what do you do i work for a financial
institution
the growth potential is limited however
if you ever bring your your product out
west i'll be at your front door
you said you have four jobs what are the
other three
i work lyft i work uber i work side job
and i donate blood
uh eight times a month wow
i work every single hour of the day i
don't go to bed till 12 o'clock one
o'clock in the morning
get up and do it all again who keeps
your kids i'm working hard at getting
this
done i want the dead done who keeps your
kids part i can't fix
pregnant who keeps your kids um the
custody of battle is basically ongoing
but i only have my daughter
which is just my little girl on the
weekends friday through monday
so i work like you know crazy when i
don't have her
and any other days that i can i work
what works i work at work
what's his financial situation
well that's multi-faceted he hides his
assets he has
six cars two paid for homes and he says
he's broke and he's a student
he makes 11.50 an hour
well dave i want to fire the attorney
but what do you say yeah i think you
need a new attorney well that's a
wonderful idea but i don't have another
attorney that'll take me either i'm
broke
i mean i really don't have the retainer
yeah
i think that's your move uh you know
here's the thing you have a 14 000 debt
to an attorney if you have a 14 000 debt
to a bank instead of an attorney it
doesn't bother me at all
i don't care where the debt is if you
want to move it
and go borrow the money to pay him off
that's fine
in the process of doing that i'm going
to fire him though
i just don't have another retainer i
know but i'm going to gather up the
money and find a way to do this
you know even if you borrowed a little
bit for a retainer
i don't care i mean uh or you sell
something or you do whatever i mean
you're just you've been
been doing this uh work your tail off
and save money for a shorter period of
time it's not been for two years
uh this but the attorney thing has been
going on for a long time
but basically basically you're getting
your butt whipped and somebody needs to
turn the
brass knuckles on your axe
metaphorically speaking understood
he's offered me a one-time 30 percent
discount do i just go get this
loan i mean i'm really out yeah he'll
knock 20
off that'd be great if he'll knock 20
off that'll be awesome
and then use that 20 percent to get the
retainer together
and borrow fourteen thousand if fourteen
thousand dollars in debt when we started
the conversation you now have fourteen
thousand dollars in debt
we finished the conversation somewhere
else and you have a new attorney
your attorney's getting his butt whipped
yeah he's terrible
he's terrible with the information you
gave dave and i a good
lawyer who actually cares about you and
wants to get this right
oh i would he would say i'll take it on
contingency because i want to take it
out of
junior boys yeah all the cars
yeah i mean you know we fixed this but
yeah yeah um
yeah this is uh the thing and here's the
thing
the other issue is is you are going to
have to continually
like you have a like you have a chronic
illness
and you're having to every month write
checks to a doctor you have a chronic
illness every month you're going to
write checks to an attorney
until you get this solved one way or
another here and i don't think
i don't think a simple retainer is going
to do it that just moves it gets it out
of his hands
and you move on but um
you know you're you're working too hard
to lose
all the time uh kelly uh tell her regina
regina let's have you call my show
sometime this week or whatever i want to
spend a little more time with her on the
shovel part you know because
we don't have enough time right now to
dive into it but i think we can get her
a bigger shovel
and that will help tremendously making
more money will help this yeah oh yeah
definitely would eric is in detroit
michigan hi eric how can we help
pretty uh thank you for taking my call
dave um i was just wondering i'm looking
at purchasing um my mom's house
i'm going to be selling my house and
purchasing hers but i just want to know
the proper way to do that i have
siblings i don't want there to be any
hard feelings of that i got a deal or
took money from her or anything
like that i just want to purchase a
house for a good price
but i don't want to overpay for it
obviously so i just
pay the asking price whatever whatever
uh um
have it appraised and pay that or i'm
not sure how to do it exactly
well i mean that's the only way
everybody's going to be happy it sounds
like because it sounds like you're super
concerned about it
so it sounds like you're going to pay
for an appraisal
are you getting a mortgage no i'm not my
house doesn't have a mortgage on it i'm
just going to sell my house and pay cash
for hers
okay yeah then i mean if you want to be
super
bureaucratic about it you hire an
independent appraiser to appraise it for
400 bucks
and you know you have an appraisal done
and you go i'm paid full appraisal i
mean who's gotta gripe with that
yeah okay now i mean i mean is that
normally uh
how i mean because we're not gonna be
using a real estate agent no it's not
normally how it would be done
normally mom would give us give her son
a discount
i was gonna say i mean she probably
would but i don't want there to be any
hard feelings between from anybody else
and it sounds like that
sounds like that that's a potential
right
like you've got siblings walking around
a little chip on their shoulder
insurance like deed insurance
or anything like that or i'm sorry i've
heard of do i need to get any kind of
insurance like deed insurance
title insurance yeah you need to get
titles yeah
i do need to get that still yeah okay
and do i just go through a broker to
you can get a title company to execute
the closing for you
they'll prepare the deed record the deed
help you know what all of the recording
costs are
you'll pay a little bit of uh legal fees
and you'll pay for a title policy how
expensive a home is this
uh i'm guessing 250 000. okay your title
policy is probably gonna be a grand
give or take is it okay something like
that and then the rest of it's probably
gonna be another 500 bucks and odds and
ends
depending on what it takes to record a
deed in your state i don't know how many
what kind of level of taxes michigan has
on
recordation but um that's what you're
talking about here
and then there's no question if you had
an appraisal that you did the right
thing and if anybody questions it
you just go this was the appraisal what
else did you want me to do
but it sounds like there's somebody in
the pile here that's not going to be
happy no matter what you do
so you better be ready for that anyway
that kind of goes with zitara tori
oh that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice ken coleman
ramsey personality best-selling author
and host of the ken coleman show
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five as we talk about your
life your career
because ken's here and questions you've
got about you know getting the
right job in the right situation
especially at the right time which is
known as
now again phone number triple eight
eight two five
five two two five preston's in sioux
falls south dakota hi preston how are
you
hi dave hi kevin how you guys doing
today better than we deserve sir how can
we help
uh dave i'm claiming to figure out if we
have self-insured and if you don't mind
i've got some numbers
give you a better picture of what i got
going on so self-insured
through what life as far as yes as far
as life insurance goes
okay i'm uh 52 my wife is 53
and we have a net worth of what i've
seen about
1.3 million good for you well done
we have a 20-year term
life insurance policy one on each of us
that exposes in six years
currently we i'm thinking about we're in
the crossroads of updating that
um or letting that lapse if i
die today um i'm figuring that my wife
should probably
have that 1.4 million in addition to
that
i have a pension with a
spousal survivor on it which is about 48
she would receive until she would value
what does she need to live a year
uh that's been my problem all right
right now uh
to replace that salary uh on that
pension
no you're going to get that she's going
to get the pension of 48 000 right
yep okay so what does she need to live a
year
she's got 48 000 how much does she need
total
i would say uh a hundred thousand a year
okay so we need another 50 grand you got
a million for what's the million for
invested got 800
investments i've got about 200 in the
home
and the rest is in the savings okay
so if the 800 produced
10 that'd be 80 000. yes
if it produced six percent um
that'd be plenty i mean you'd still be
there
okay and so the other thing i was
looking at in
uh six years when that uh the policy
that we have
expires i'm going to assume that that
800
should be above about 1.6 would you
agree with that
yeah 800 in investments you should
double on it pretty close to double that
yep okay assuming it's invested in good
mutual funds and you're making a
you know a 10 plus percent rate of
return that would get you there
we've been following your plan for 25
years and it's all on the spouse with
victory
and that plane that you put on there it
works and if anybody's questioning it
they feel free to give me a call it
works
on a different level so you didn't you
didn't inherit this money this is all
from the ground
i didn't up not one time in fact uh when
our parents when when my
parents died uh i was fortunate enough
because of you
they actually pay for females um
we came from a different account and uh
if we can do it
or anyone can do it well way to go i'm
very proud of you excellent job
i just removed his laughter when you
said so you
you didn't inherit this from the ground
up and he just laughed
a laugh of that sort of knowledge that's
absurd
yeah of no and he was reminiscing
the journey while he chuckled you gotta
love that yeah
i mean you really have to be out of
touch with life
and have your head stuck up some kind of
twisted ideology to think that people
build wealth by inheritance
because it is such a small percentage of
wealthy people
that did not do it themselves um i mean
of all the 10 000 millionaires we
studied
we found well in excess of 90 percent
inherited either not enough nothing
or not enough to have made the
millionaires they got 5 000 inheritance
or something like that
uh it's about 93 percent of millionaires
in america
wow our millionaires because of their
own saving yeah and so
and like he said you come from a
neighborhood where you end up having to
pay for your own mom and dad's funeral
and uh so i mean that's not exactly
uh privileged no not in terms of a
racial thing but in terms of a
an economic thing yeah nothing handed to
them they they earned it
you know there was also high percentage
uh and i wish i knew it my brain's a
little little slow on it
you may know it high percentage of those
everyday millionaires also
loved their work 68 68
thank you as opposed to 68 of the public
hate their work
yeah that's exactly what it is 80
internationally
and so what that says to me is is that
when you when you enjoy your work and
you find meaning in it
you'll work a little harder because you
enjoy it you'll go a little harder to
make more money not only harder but you
just tend to be
better well you do better there's no
question your performance is better no
question yeah and so you make more money
yeah you get promoted you make more
money
you invest wisely and you're 52 years of
age and he's self-insured
yeah is what the answer is a 52-year-old
millionaire
1.4 million 52 is young dave well that
our average was 51.
wow in the study that that's when they
got there now he's been a millionaire a
while
he was a millionaire several years ago
already because he's at a million four
right now
but um that's exactly what chris hogan
found
and and our team found when we did all
the research and he published we
published it in the book everyday
millionaires
and the white paper that you can even
get uh at daveramsey.com if you want to
read the whole thing
but and it's not to uh sometimes i get
accused of shaming people it's not
shaming people
it's quite the opposite it's saying
anyone can do it
that's right anyone can do it i'm so
dumb i did it twice
[Laughter]
see that gives you that authority though
hey i've done it twice
i was a millionaire by the time i was 26
and i lost it all because it was stupid
hey one of the most staggering uh pieces
of data from that study i remember when
chris first shader team about fell out
of the chair but i was so excited to
hear that i think the third largest
group were teachers
now i know for a fact that the median
salary in the united states for teachers
is 60 000.
you soak on that for a minute just in
case you're going well this guy
who knows what he did no no no no that's
not
in america and so so here's what
teachers do teachers believe in
processes
and they steadily invest and steadily
invest and if you put 15
of your income away and you make fifty
thousand dollars a year
you'll have five million dollars at
retirement not one
you know but you can't put fifteen
percent away because you're driving a
car you can't afford
you got a boat in the backyard they cost
you five hundred dollars a minute
for with the use that you actually get
out of it considering the insurance the
depreciation
and the payments you're paying on it um
i'll going to boat people in the middle
of winter yeah there you go i was
thinking about a boat now dave just
completely
flashed up no no boat for me this year
it's true though but it's doable that's
the point it's doable it's very doable
very doable this is the ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today let's get real for a
minute some of you are getting close to
baby step four
and you're freaking out because you know
you need to save 15
of your income for retirement you have
no idea how to start investing it's all
brand new to you
it's okay a lot of people got questions
it's brand new you got to have somebody
help you with it you have somebody to
walk with you you need a pro like a
smart investor
pro they can answer all the questions
that you have in
plain english they do not sound like
people in the industry
sometimes sound like charlie brown's
teacher like
wawa you don't even know who charlie
brown's teacher is i do yeah
because you know when it comes to
investing you need to know what you are
investing in you need to understand
you need to sit down and work with a
smart investor pro that has the heart of
a teacher
and they're going to teach you what's
going on so never again do you need to
sit around freaking out
take your time learn learn learn
learn learn invest based on that if you
want to get ready
it's time to do it time to start
investing text the word invest
seven 233 nine text invest two three
three seven eight nine
reagan is with us in california i'm
sorry cleveland ohio hi reagan how are
you
hi dave hi ken how are you guys better
than i deserve what's up
so i've got a question for you uh i'm 24
right now and i'm
actually on my trial period of ramsey
ramsay plus i'm working on getting all
my finances in order where they need to
be
um i'm on i guess baby step two i'm
finishing up grad school one day and i
just accepted
a job offer that starts on march 1st my
question is
i'm getting engaged in about a week and
a half congratulations
yeah thank you and i'm curious who i
should put
as the beneficiary of a term life and uh
term life insurance policy i'm about to
take one out
about after i get engaged and i know
you're a big proponent of keeping
finances separate until marriage i was
just wondering
should i quit her as a beneficiary
i wouldn't i mean
unless you have a child with her do you
no sir no sir
okay then no i mean i i would not put
her
i would change it to her name as soon as
you get home from the honeymoon
or the week before marriage or whatever
something like that but
um i i suspect you're going to be
engaged a little while and you're
probably not going to get married two
weeks later right
yes sir i think that um we're shooting
for something like january of
2022. yeah i i would just put so i don't
even know that you
yeah you can go and get some term
insurance if you want to but you know
and truthfully changing the beneficiary
on your term life insurance is not that
big a deal it's not that hard to do
it's a one-page form if you do it analog
if you do it digital it's no big deal at
all
uh but yeah i i would not i would name a
you know like your parents or somebody
like that as a beneficiary right now
and then after you're married i would
change it
you're right i'm a big proponent of
keeping it separate
and the opposite is true for those of
you out there when you do get married
you do need to change it
ken we had a call um
i think it was hogan me on the air a
couple of weeks ago
that uh the couple had been married
seven years and he died
and he had never changed his
beneficiaries and his
dad got all his 401k got all his life
insurance
and he had three kids they've been
married seven years
and he'd never gone in and changed it so
me and hogan had a bit of a rant
there on get your dadgum stuff changed
it's the opposite in the spectrum of
this guy but
yeah you know you you get married you
need to sit down and
go through the paperwork and be a
grown-up
and you know make sure your
beneficiaries are all changed to your
new spouse i've got a question for you
and it's a true
technical quote maybe it's too small so
help me um why wouldn't he
the day before a couple of days before
the wedding go ahead and get it changed
then
yeah in case something that'd be fine
awful which you don't want to think
you know week before week after but not
not not no not a year
not a year ahead because too many things
happen too many things can go on
and then you know it's um
you know i'm not even sure you need life
insurance until you get married
that's true in this case yeah so i mean
if you were a single guy
out there i i'm that might be the answer
it might be that you wait
yeah i was wondering what what's the
what's the benefit now if there's a
benefit of this new job
that's termed life insurance and they're
providing it here it's going to name a
beneficiary then that's a different
thing
right but i thought he said he was
purchasing he did say that and i was
wondering why
why would a single guy need to get done
insurance doesn't
okay yeah you don't um if you're single
and you have a little bit of money in
the bank to bury you if something
happened to you
um then i really yeah outside of that
that's the only one you don't
need a bunch of life insurance at that
stage of the game he's just a
responsible young man he's
very excited he's just got his first job
congratulations
he's getting engaged he just is trying
to check boxes off
he's doing the right thing he is she's
being smart about all that so good stuff
brad's with us in wisconsin appleton to
be precise hi brad how are you
good dave uh pleasure to talk to you
first time uh
call or long time listener well thank
you how can we help
well quick question i'm 53 years old my
wife is 51
we are everyday millionaires thanks to
you and your guys and your program
great um but i do have one small debt uh
that it wasn't about death my whole
mortgage just slow forty five thousand
that has eaten me i want that gone
um we do have uh to each have a variable
life insurance policy which
cash value is about 35 000 in there
would you recommend taking that out and
just throwing it at the mortgage and
leaving you with ten thousand dollars
left piano
yeah yeah what's your hand what's your
you don't have ten thousand dollars
laying around in an account somewhere
well yeah you do yes
yeah so let's just pay it off i mean i
don't wanna just you know come up short
but
but the answer is yeah i would pay off
your mortgage and yes i would cash out
variable life insurance now
if you do need term life insurance you
would need to get that in place first
now
you said you're everyday millionaires
are you in a position that if something
happened to you without any life
insurance that she would be okay
yes she's a teacher she makes about
sixty thousand dollars and we have no
other debt available you know we have no
other debt
i make plenty to to cover that person as
well so and you have
substantial investments it sounds like
uh about eight hundred and twenty
thousand dollars i believe in in ten
investments yes
okay now and so that money could be
invested and create an income
to replace your income if something
happened to you
yes okay then you know if you if you
consider yourself self-insured then you
don't need
you know and it sounds like you are uh
if the kids are grown and gone and
mortgages paid off i mean you're in
great shape so yeah i'm gonna i'm
cashing that puppy out
it's a horrible place to have money and
the little tiny mortgage is a horrible
thing so let's just get rid of a bunch
of horrible things
one conversation and a celebration you
can tell
it's really nagging at him touchdown i
don't know if he caught that go
like you can pay that off today yeah
dave said
you're free coach yeah you probably got
45 000 in one of those other accounts
you could just write a checklist
yeah and pay it off it's not in a
retirement account
and then just replenish it with this now
don't if if you
only have 45 000 cash to your name
anywhere
then don't do that but i suspect that
you know i'm hearing
i'm hearing lots of zeros in this
discussion so i think you're okay
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five aaron is with us in louisville
kentucky hi erin how are you
i'm doing great how about yourself
better than we deserve how can we help
so i probably geared more towards mr
coleman
um i am at currently the job that i'm at
isn't a bad job i just don't really make
a whole lot of money
but it is pretty secure you know um when
everything was shut down or whatever
i still had my job and it was considered
it's
quote unquote central whatever sure but
i have to really work
a lot of hours to really make any
halfway decent money and so i just don't
want to do that forever
i'd like to start pursuing trying to
find something better
but i'll just be honest i'm fearful that
you know
as soon as i go out get something
something crazy happens they shut down
again
and then i can't work whatever job that
i'm getting
let me let me set you free i get that
we'll come back to you after this
correct we can get to that okay we're
gonna come back to you after this break
i'm gonna put you on hold yes
and bring you back around aaron uh
because we've
i want to give you a good solid answer
and let ken spend a minute with you
right here this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show ken
coleman ramsey personality
is my co-host today we're talking with
aaron in louisville kentucky
and uh ken i'll let you pick it up yeah
so aaron uh where we left off we went to
the break
you're in a situation where you've got a
good stable job
but for you to make any decent money
you're having to work some crazy hours
and your concern is if you go take
something else and do something else
which is what i heard you say you want
to do
you're worried that if things go bad
you're going to be stuck
and you'll have left a stable job so
there's some fear there did i about
capture that
did the the nail or the hammer on the
nail
okay great so let's just talk about what
you want to go
do what is it that you want to go do
describe that type of work
well i mean i mean if i could pick
anything i mean i would
try to grow a couple of my photography
business
but as far as just to go enter another
job i mean
no hold on hold on i love this hold on i
love this let's talk about the plan to
go do what you really want to do which
is photography
so is that tell me about that is that
weddings
all types of family photography what is
that what does that look like
uh i mean currently that looks like
anything that i can take a photo
of honestly i mean right i mean weddings
is
you make there is really good money in
weddings you do you know portraits
uh well enough you know there's decent
nightmare as well so my the reason i ask
that is that the type of photography
that you want to do
um i i don't really have anything
specific
you know that i want to do in that i
just want to take photos i guess
okay all right so so here's what we
wanted okay that's okay
so what i want you to do i've got a
quick homework assignment for you over
the next couple days i want you to begin
to
make a list of the type of photography
that you most love to look at
what what moves you when you see photos
what kind of photos is it photos of
cars classic cars is it photos of
sunsets i don't care what it is
but i think you got to get in tune with
this is the kind of photography that i
get inspired by that i like to consume
make a list of people who are doing that
begin to look into that and do some
research into what that looks like how
you can get paid what those rates look
like just become a student
of that future because that's what you
want to do now let's move to a better
day job
what do you think from a talent
standpoint that you could go do
in your area louisville kentucky uh and
put yourself in a much better paid
situation what would you look at just
another day job that's more stable
what are you thinking you know
honestly i don't know i i i you know
what i was thinking about was just
trying just hitting the streets and just
trying to see
who's offering jobs and you know what
what hours they're offering and
i mean i'd like to be in somewhere
that's somewhat kind of like what i as
far as hours go what i do
now as far as like i i start work real
early in the morning
and and there's the potential of getting
off at a decent time during the day
where i still have time to spend with my
family
but you know like i said i'll go to do
even do that i just don't make enough
money but sure okay so here's the deal
something that paid better that had
those kind of hours all right so here's
what i want you to do i want you to
think about what you
do best just your basic talents that you
can that you can take to the marketplace
and you're good at your job now correct
yes sir what do you do i'm a
mailman i don't work directly for the
post office i work for a contractor that
can
correct myself so let's look at other
jobs let's just start looking in
louisville kentucky right now with jobs
where you can be in a car
you can set your own schedule certainly
that early morning because you've got a
nice rhythm there let's look where i can
make some money driving whether that's a
delivery truck you know for
you've got your national companies
you've got local companies you've got
food delivery
just start looking to anybody out there
that's looking for a very dependable
driver
delivery maybe some logistics work maybe
in a warehouse
you've just got to say hey here's what i
bring to the table i'm dependable i can
do this
and you start looking out there and
saying these are the jobs that are out
there and this is what they pay
they pay more than i'm being that i'm
being paid now and i don't have to work
as many hours this is just a simple
research play turning over rocks
and find it now i want to address your
fear unless you're
applying for something that is some
brand new company
some startup that has no history you
have enough common sense i trust you
aaron to be able to determine whether or
not
this is a risky move and it's not a
risky move because the reality is the
type of work you're doing
and the type of work you can do you
don't need to worry about it
disappearing you just can't live life
that way just move forward go get a
better paying job
that you don't have to work these crazy
hours and for the amount of hours you're
working maybe you get two jobs hey aaron
is this safe to say your job sucks
well yeah it's safe to say that
and it's steady so it steadily sucks
right
yeah steady's not all it steadily sucks
i guess the thing
dude dude say that i mean really you
need to hear that
and let me just tell you if you keep
doing what you've been doing
you're gonna keep getting what you've
been getting yeah so it is time to do
something different i don't know
you can change your day job you can
start the car the photo thing on the
side
definitely do let's let's do something
yeah
because because right now we got sucks
on steady yeah and by the way if
something good falls apart
sucks still there you can go back to it
there's nothing to be afraid of here
there's nothing to be afraid of well i
mean yeah
i'm afraid that you continue to do what
you're doing that's what i'm afraid oh i
like that that's exactly right but
here's the thing
here's the thing there there is no
security no none except your own ability
that's right and you're not even using
your own ability here
you you know you're just you you've got
an entry-level
base yeah job that sucks
and you know and so you're not even you
you're really not
losing anything if you lost this because
you know if you can develop a skill
you're always going to be employed at
that skill
yep because you know that you're you're
only as secure
as your ability to go land something
else and you if you apparently if you're
breathing you can land this job that's
right but see here's where his fear is
coming from his fear is coming from
he simply doesn't know he hasn't done
the research to see all the different
types of jobs
once we see one job two job three job
four job five jobs
seven jobs you go wait a second oh i can
do those now i'm not so afraid but it's
that we talked about this before
people would would rather deal with the
misery than the uncomfortableness and so
he just needs that nudge
go the devil we know go find it and then
do it
yeah it's just here here's the thing
it's
you're stuck and you got to get unstuck
yeah i mean but you've dug your own
ditch here this is you're
you know you know what a rut is it's
exactly to say it's a grave with both
ends kicked out
that's exactly right nobody says it
better than that that's what it is and
by the way this is a rut of your own
doing
yeah so change it yeah today if you keep
doing
if you do nothing that ken just told you
to do and a year from now you're still
doing that
yeah it's your fault that's right your
fault let's start
let me tell you you're being paid about
half of what you're probably worth
oh absolutely he's driving a mail truck
i'm looking for a local company that
does a lot of deliveries they've got
manufacturing auto parts i'm looking
forward to feeling doing uber eats he
could double his income oh
for sure by the way let's talk about the
security thing because you just
mentioned it made me think about this i
get this call
it's a false thing total i get this call
a lot on the ken coleman show you ready
for this hey ken
having made payroll as a small business
guy
and the first 10 years of this business
the people were on my payroll i'm scared
i'm scratching trying to make sure i got
the money to make payroll on friday
and they thought they had a secure job
yeah if you've ever made payroll you
know nobody is secure
that's right that's right we get this
call a lot uh ken i'm on a contract
right now and my contract's coming up
and i just i feel like i got to move
into something with a more stable salary
they think salary versus contract and
the reality is you could be a salary
employee and get fired
let go furlough just ask the pandemic
yeah so just because you have a salary
position doesn't mean that you're
immune to having your job removed from
you well i mean
here's an idea if you're self-employed
and you have your own photography
company
every day you get up you leave the cave
you kill something and you drag it home
that's called security
there you go that's where security comes
from yeah and i remember i was making
you know serious money the first time i
ever got up close to seven figures
and uh my sweet granny who uh
my grandpa worked for one company for 38
years never changed
because he lost everything in the
depression and he was so thankful for
the job
that he never left of course never left
and uh that that generation did that
this generation these last generations
don't including mine but i mean i'm
making serious
bank owning my own business and my sweet
granny would say now honey when you
gonna get a real job
wow she still want me to get secure yes
you know and she's sweet as she could be
god rest her soul yes
but she wanted me to be secure and i was
making more
yeah you know it was you know just but
you know self-employed get up
leave the cave kill something drag it
home man
and you you got to change it aaron you
got to change it man
just because it's steady it just
steadily sucks
change it
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
our scripture of the day first peter 1
13
therefore preparing your minds for
action and being sober minded
set your hope fully on the grace that
will be brought to you
at the revelation of jesus christ
john f kennedy said there are risks and
costs
to action but they are far less than
doing the long
range risks of than the than the long
range risks of comfortable
inaction yeah exactly what we were just
talking about i've been talking a lot
about that yeah so that's for our last
caller there are risks
and costs to action but they are far
less than the long range risks
of comfortable in action the way i like
to say it is would you rather get to the
end of your life and reminisce
or would you have to regret or regret
yeah it's a
nasty taste in the back of your mouth
dawn is with us in asheville north
carolina hey don what's up
hi dave can you hear me yes
oh good thank you so much for taking my
call
it's a blessing to talk to you uh i have
a friend
who is dealing with the offer of a lump
sum settlement and i know you're gonna
say to take it
but she and i have run the numbers and i
can't figure out why she should take it
okay a lump sum settlement on a lawsuit
no no um she her husband was disabled
and died and she
gets monthly payments from the state of
new york
and they have offered now that her
youngest child is no longer a minor
they've offered
to pay out a lump sum instead of
continuing to send her
uh the money every month okay and how
much was the lump sum
okay the lump sum is
000 and how much are her payments she's
receiving
she's 61 years old and she gets 2 000 a
month
uh tax free okay so she's getting 24 000
and she gets 225 and when she dies the
payments
stop right that's correct
and when she dies if she has 225 000 in
the account
that goes to her heirs correct
yes sir did you have that number in your
mind
it's a 225 000. there's a 225 000
swing at death yes
0 or 225 000 at death and if you invest
225 000 well
she will make almost as much
or as much as she's making now although
it will be taxable
okay so she made 10 to be 22 000 a year
that's 29 24 000 a year
but i mean if you invest it well she'd
be able to get 24 000 a year out of it
and uh and there'd be money left at
death
okay so the my own
when i ran the numbers because the state
says they use 87 as their life
expectancy and when i ran the numbers it
was
like 647 000. that's not how the numbers
work
okay the numbers work on what is your
monthly income
off of the lump sum and the lump sum
survives death
it's not a total dollar because you're
you're looking at
how much i need to use the lump sum for
her to get as much
income as she would have gotten
otherwise
and in this case it's very you are right
it is very unusual
in that she might actually make less per
month if she takes the lump sum and
invests it even invests it well
so what i'd recommend you do is sit with
her with a smartvestor pro
and have someone actually map out some
real investments
and not just deal with theory here on
the air and let's consider then what she
could really do
but the big difference here is upon
death
there's not going to be a big difference
while she's alive
because it's not like they're paying her
like it's seven percent and she could
make 12
or make 10. that sounds like she's got a
really nice income
it actually sounds like they've
miscalculated this
i think they've screwed up the
calculation i would go back to them and
tell and ask them
they say the lump sum seems awfully
small i think you made a mistake would
you check your calculation
because i think the lump sum should be
bigger
because i can't believe the state of
freak in new york is competent enough to
have run the numbers out based on a 12
rate of return they didn't they've not
got that money invested at that i just
tell you they're not that smart
okay i mean this is a state government
number one and it's the state of new
york
number two so let's just keep this in
mind
what are you saying dave what am i
saying i don't know if i understand what
you're saying dave i'm just what do you
get are you getting to something yeah
i'm saying i'm saying i think i have a
math problem here i think you're right
yeah so anyway
sit down i would go back and challenge
them on the lump sum yeah and then the
second thing i would do is get a a smart
vester pro click smart vester at
daveramsey.com
sit down with them or get them on a zoom
or whatever you need to do in your area
to feel comfortable and all that stuff
uh and um you know run some numbers out
on some real
investments you can run what's called a
hypothetical
on a mutual fund portfolio and you say
if we bought these four mutual funds
and we had owned them for the last 20
years what would they have turned out to
be
and what would that what kind of income
would they have created and that's
called a hypothetical analysis and
it is using the history but to project
the future which you can't technically
do
you know you remember that you know a
stupid butt line they use that the feds
make everybody use in the investment
world is
you know past history is not indicative
of the future
of course it is right that's just stupid
jared is in colorado springs hey jared
how are you
i'm doing well good afternoon dave and
ken how are you guys great man how can
we help
well we have a rental um and i
am contemplating selling it it's
actually my wife's
old house before we got married but
um i think it might be a peak time to
sell in colorado
and i'm afraid of what the market's
going to do it's been a really
consistent rental for
the past six years um what are your
thoughts on selling to in order to pay
off
our home mortgage not a bad idea
uh the i would not use the fact that i
think that the real estate market is
going to go down
in colorado springs is my reason because
i don't think that's true
okay okay colorado springs is a vibrant
awesome market it's got that proximity
to denver and denver's
nuts on real estate prices and so
it's a wonderful town i mean colorado
springs is an incredible place
to live work own real estate everything
and so i i don't think you're going to
see
prices go down there in the future but
if you're done with rentals you've had a
nice run and you'd like to use that
money to pay off your mortgage you'd
love the idea of being completely debt
free
hey dave ramsey not going to argue with
you on that dude
laura is with us laura's in new york
city hi laura welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi thank you for having me sure how can
we help
well i am a licensed massage therapist
and
a dancer and i'm wondering if i should
change professions my parents think i
should go back to school
because the job mark is hard with the
things that i do
and you're a licensed therapist and a
dancer
yes are you a professional dancer as in
broadway
i'm a professional dancer i have not
done broadway
okay um have you made a living doing
that or have you made your living as
a therapist i have currently been making
my living as a licensed massage
therapist
okay okay but it doesn't sound like you
want to go back to school sounds like
mom and dad think you should go back to
school
please don't live their dream yeah
yeah that's the problem actually i have
been living or doing for
a while that's also why i went into
massage therapy
what do you want to do what do you
dreamed about you've dreamed about
something anybody that's creative like
you has had a dream you've got no
problem with imagination
what is it what do you want to do
i wouldn't do acting but i i mean i have
been
i've been auditioning i did get some
small like background
okay so listen laura i want to set you
free in order for you be an actor you
got to stay in it this is a long game
and i can't speak to your talent i'm
assuming right now that you're not
delusional that you actually have the
talent to do it
uh you've got to be a massage therapist
or something else you've got to have a
day
job or two that gives you the
flexibility to audition that is simply
the game we're in nashville we always
say how do you get the next country
music star's attention
uh waiter order an appetizer yeah you
you're gonna have a plan that gives you
the freedom to keep pursuing don't you
give up
there's always a chance to go back to
something else but you need to walk
through this and figure out what your
long-term dream is has it shifted
but don't live your mama's dream that's
a bad plan right there that's not gonna
even make her happy
not gonna work out for you that puts us
hour of the ramsey show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
you